Three Thrives tell us what's the Ivory
continent remained a mystery, the jungle, the climate, fevers, and sometimes the hostility
of the natives. There were insects and wild animals and so many barriers and dangers to
discourage exploration. Then, technical progress made in the 19th century would give the Europeans
the encouragement and the means to explore the dark continent. In England, Sir Joseph
banks founds the association for the exploration of africa one-third of all is a completely unknown
especially in africa there's a whole continent to be discovered simply in the interests of
science it's our duty to explore it so the association funds the first european expedition
into the interior of the continent a certain scotsman mongo park manages to get as far as
the niger river but the niger is a wild river and he was unable to tame it next the turn of a young
Frenchman, René Callier, he spoke Arabic and had studied the Koran, and he set off from
Senegal disguised as a pilgrim. He would be the first European ever to arrive at the legendary
city of Timbuktu, off in the middle of the desert. Surely there were many others from
many other lands, but the most extraordinary was surely a Scotsman whose name was David
Livingston. At the age of 25 and with diplomas in medicine and theology, he arrives in South
African sets up a mission north of Kourouma. Before long, he married the daughter of the
local clergyman. Human wisdom comes from our lord. Settlers who were at war with the English
and took a very dim view of his mission. To leave our home. Yeah, but crossing the Kalahari
desert would prove dangerous. Too dangerous for you and the children. Better go on back
to England with you to Cape Town. Wife and children behind Livingston pursued his undying
passion exploration is our last one european animals are especially vulnerable to the sleeping
sickness caused by the tsitsi fly zambesi we'll cross it but with slaves it can't be allowed
must help those poor people get the distress flares cross the sea you saved us so you're
our friend we are the moco lolos this is our tribal land please come with us dr livingston
our chief will be glad to meet you saved us all from the slave traders
Zekeletu, King of Makalolos, you helped my people. I will give you help. You've only to say what you want.
Just one thing. I want to explore your mountains, your rivers, make roads, open up your land to civilization, put an end to slavery.
If I might go from here all the way to the Great Sea, an ocean thousands of times greater than your biggest lakes, it would be good for your people.
You'll have supplies and be escorted by my warriors.
Livingston took five months to cover the 2,000-kilometer journey to Luanda, capital of Portuguese Angola.
He would cross five great rivers, and the trip proved to be much more difficult than he could have ever imagined.
With every step, he met new challenges, and finally, here he is in Luanda.
Four!
Discipline malaria, man-eating crocodiles, what more? That's enough.
Just in time!
Months of rest.
What?
Losing time?
Bad Doc made a big decision.
We're going to cross Africa from end to end in a straight line.
News, it's easy.
First, back to the Mokalolos to see their king.
From sea to sea.
From rising sun to setting sun.
Haha!
You will need additional mules and more ivory if you're going so far.
You shall have them.
Rumbling smoke.
Over this falls, Victoria, in honor of our gracious queen.
Let's go.
There's a long trek ahead.
Slave traders must have come.
Way him to pass through his territory.
Alright, bring him some.
After eight months, Livingston, exhausted and sick, finally reached Calimani,
the first European to cross Africa from west to east.
He had crossed the entire continent.
Returning to England after a 15-year absence, he's given a hero's welcome.
For if we want to open Africa and exploit its riches,
and put an end to the wicked slave trade,
we must bring Africa our civilization, as well as Christianity and trade.
So appointed as consul to East Africa, Livingston returned to the Black Continent.
His mission? Open a navigable waterway on the Zambezi.
The boat is slow, much too slow!
Oh-ho, sir.
Yes, that's right.
Oh yes, I see all right.
His answer to Europe's is technological marvel.
The same, it helped him to discover beautiful Lake Nyassa.
Good return trip.
Sir, you're a tough nut, aren't you?
London's always sending me ballroom explorers with no backbone in 'em.
I think I'll just get started on my own with my porters and my buffaloes.
I'd like to go along with you this time, but we're old and pretty tired now, doctor.
But if you like, our sons, Sudsy and Chuma, could go with you.
Then disappeared. He was swallowed up by the African jungle.
Many people in Europe were concerned about Livingston, but nobody did anything,
and then an American newspaper funded a search expedition.
Yeah, yeah, Stanley, yeah.
Um, you are the only one who can go to Africa and find David Livingston.
The scope of the century.
Difficult, Mr. Bennett, and costly, very costly.
Livingston's methods aren't mine.
Anything you want, just ask for it right your own ticket.
Our job is to find Livingston as quick as we can.
There aren't going to be any stops or delays,
and anybody who tries to desert gets punished.
Everybody got that?
Oh, they did.
Every one of them, he means you, Lensie Bones, we're hard.
My namuaza are the best porters around.
Go on, you ask anybody.
Yes, you be.
That is exactly where my men said they had word of him.
It is a thousand kilometers away, and it will be very rough going.
Let's go.
This is excellent.
A certain white...
Gigi is one with a white beard.
A new Gigi.
That's what they said.
Yes, that could be him.
I think we'll find him.
We're off again.
Exceedingly tired to me, boss. A little rest would be good.
Just look at them.
Yes, we're tired.
We want to stop.
Not till we find Livingston.
Then we'll stop.
Every man will be rewarded.
But now, just one order: the trail!
Finally, they get to use it.
It was here that he spoke the sentence that went down in history.
Dr. Livingston, I presume?
Yes, I suppose, huh?
Dr. I'm very glad. At last we meet.
Pleasure, sir. Traveling, sir.
I'm well-funded.
Doctor, in Europe, everybody's concerned about you.
Just in time. My surprise would have run out in about two weeks.
We can return together, Doctor. It'll be a pleasure.
What? Return?
I'll take you back to England, Doctor.
Stanley, when I decide to return to England, I don't need anybody.
I... I'll get myself.
Very well. If you want to remain, I can't make you go back.
Listen to me, Stanley. These are my notes for the past two years.
If anything happens to me, all my work won't be lost.
Yes, but why don't you want to come back home?
Young man, you have given me strength and hope. My place is here.
Anyway, I'm going to find the source of the Nile.
Let's go, lads. We're on our way again.
The person wouldn't go for the rainy season, he lost his way.
Stanley, take up the challenge.
He mounted the most extensive expedition ever seen in Africa.
Eight tons of supplies and equipment carried by 360 porters, and he set off to explore the Congo.
The Lualabar and I believe it flows directly into the Congo.
About half the men have deserted, and we are in the middle of nowhere.
With the Lady Alice on the water, we'll make progress. On our own.
What's more, Chibi-Tupu will help us.
Why do you have anything to do with that slave trader? Why?
With him here, the porters won't run away.
Do it.
Seen a white man scared.
Two skirmishes with the natives and spread terror as he forced a passageway on the Congo River.
His fierce determination earned him the name "Rock Breaker".
Now they know what's in store if they attack us.
Their journey went on like this to Boma on the Atlantic.
It was of torture to reach the coast, but Stanley's exploit was to change many things.
He had opened up Africa and all its riches were squabbled over by Europeans.
Get the way I was here first, I had some mad rage.
And the winner, he met his country's flag first.
And he returned to the Congo and made it the Belgian Congo.
British subject came and gave his name to British Cameroon.
A Frenchman, Pierre de Brazza, would found Brazzaville.
Each explorer is happy to immortalize his name.
Soon Africa was exploited in a way far different
from the humanitarian dreams of Livingston.
Ah, Africa, that is even today so mysterious.